Throughout the history of modern warfare,
the record for longest confirmed sniper kill
is one that has steadily gotten more and more
extreme as technology has progressed.
At the time of writing this, the holder of
that record is British sniper Craig Harrison,
who notably broke the previous record twice
on the same day by hitting two enemy targets
on two consecutive shots an astounding 2,474
metres away.
For our friends across the pond, that’s
8,116.8 feet or 1.54 miles or about 22.5 NFL
football fields (including end zones) away.
The shot was from such an extreme range that
it took the bullet about three seconds to
reach the target.
Corporal of Horse Craig Harrison made his
record breaking shot in November of 2009 while
stationed in the Helmand Province of Afghanistan.
Harrison personally didn’t find out about
its record breaking nature until after he
returned home in 2010.
The distance from which he took the shot,
which was measured and confirmed via GPS,
amazed his superiors in the Ministry of Defence
so much that they published the details of
his shot almost as soon as he got back to
the UK, and even granted him permission to
give interviews about it to the world’s
media.
If you’re wondering about the circumstances
surrounding the shot, Harrison was providing
cover fire for his commanding officer and
members of the Afghan National Army, who’d
been ambushed by two insurgents.
According to Harrison, the insurgents were
armed with a PKM machine-gun and had pinned
down the soldiers, giving him only a short
time to assess the situation and subsequently
line up a shot to ruin the attackers’ day.
With a help from a spotter, Cliff O’Farrell,
and 9 test shots to nail down the exact distance,
Harrison lined up his shot and squeezed the
trigger for a 10th time, firing a .338 Lapua
Magnum round and striking the machine-gunner
in the gut, killing him.
The remaining insurgent, who wouldn’t have
even heard the shot coming, reached out to
take command of the now free machine-gun only
to be hit by a second round launched by Harrison.
With both insurgents down, Harrison pulled
the trigger one more time to disable the machine-gun
itself.
Thus, Harrison not only broke the previous
record (7,972 feet set in 2002 in Afghanistan)
held by Canadian Rob Furlong using a McMillan-Tac
50, but he made the shot essentially three
times in a row without missing- hitting the
two insurgents and their machine-gun.
This means he technically broke the record
twice within a few seconds of one another.
As if all that wasn’t impressive enough,
the actual shots were noted as being about
3,000 feet beyond the L115A3 rifle’s effective
range.
Needless to say, as Harrison said, “Conditions
were perfect, no wind, mild weather, clear
visibility”.
Interestingly, despite the interviews he gave
over the matter, we shouldn’t really know
Harrison’s real name.
Official Ministry of Defence rules state that
the identities of snipers, regardless of interviews
of this nature, should never be disclosed
publicly, as they would quickly become prime
targets.
Harrison was well aware of this rule and reportedly
only agreed to speak with the media about
his record shot on the understanding that
his identity wouldn’t be disclosed or that
they’d give him a pseudonym.
However, for reasons that aren’t clear,
the MoD never passed this restriction onto
any of the media outlets Harrison spoke with
and they all released stories crediting Harrison
under his real name, with some sources even
noting where he lived.
The police quickly warned Harrison and his
family that they were in danger after the
story was printed.
To protect his wife, daughter, and himself,
Harrison was left with no choice but to uproot
his family, which in turn resulted in his
wife losing her job and his daughter being
pulled from school mid-year.
We’re also guessing that for the following
few months, Harrison ensured that his wife
and daughter were always within 8000 feet
of his location, just in case.
Understandably, Harrison got pretty upset
about his identity being printed in the news
when he was explicitly told it wouldn’t
be.
Thus, he asked the MoD for compensation for
drawing a bullseye on his family’s backs
and to cover moving expenses.
He was later awarded £100,000 (about $156,000)
for
his trouble.